هذا هو مركز مدينه موسكو وقد اصبحت تتنفس
الصعداء بعدما اصدر الستار على التمرد
المسلح لمجموعه فاجنر والذي وصل ضواحي
العاصمه الروسيه شوارع المدينه تعيش
حياتها الطبيعيه والمشهد هنا يخلو من
مظاهر التواجد الامني مع الاحتفاظ بوضع
مكافحه الارهاب وتعليق كافه الفعاليات
الجماعيه واغلاق اماكن التجمعات امام
الزوار كالساحه الحمراء والحدائق العامه
وغيرها كذلك
الحديث عن اننا لم نشعر بالقلق غير صحيح
كنت مع اصدقائي في حفله عيد ميلاد وعرفنا
من الاخبار عن التمرد مساء الجمعه وكنا
نراقب الوضع صباح السبت لنكون بخير
اليوم هو افضل من الامس الاخبار جيده وكل
الاطراف تصرفت بحكمه وبعقليه متوازنه
والله ساعدنا خلال هذه الازمه
الكابوس الذي القى بظلاله على سكان الجنوب
الروسي لم يكن واقعه على سكان موسكو
بالحده ذاتها المرافق العامه ومطاعم
المدينه والمحال التجاريه ما زالت تعمل
بوضعها الطبيعي باستثنائي اغلاق بعض
الطرقات في الخارج باتجاه الجنوب والغرب
تحسبا لاي طارق عبد الجواد الرشد العربيه